okay the spot doesn't exactly use tech
it's an artist warehouse in a Sydney
suburb but move deeper through the
creative commune and you'll find a
makeshift science lab and this guy one
of its founders the transhumanist
polyamorous biohacker you all know the
type welcome to why foundry Australia's
first open access molecular biology lab
Sinister's that can sometimes sound
biohacking has turned into an exciting
new field
it's do-it-yourself meddling with DNA on
the cheap to tweak nature and this is
Australia's first biohacker lab open to
anyone willing to pay a membership fee
let's get into it in the name of this
biohacking pioneer meow meow do you
prefer to be a mr. mail mr. meow meows
meows fine
meow hit up Jenner's friends for a lot
of the scientific year and he hopes the
lab will inspire people of all stripes
to give biotech a try
it's about pulling people in with
hands-on experiments like extracting DNA
from the strawberry if you stir up where
the alcohol touches the strawberries you
be able to pull out some stringy stuff
and that's the DNA so that's the
instructions to make a strawberry this
is the first step in a biohack lab
pretty much anything we're doing with
molecular biology we're gonna need to
get that DNA out the flavor genes the
pigment genes we can take these genes
out and put them in other things so you
might want to make an apple that tastes
like a strawberries you might be able to
take the pigment genes out make a new
type of paint so you kind of take the
most interesting properties of some
organism extract it out and then maybe
chuck it into something else and give it
some new superpowers that's it yeah like
everything block a molecular biologist
by training Miao has put the lab to work
on real projects ranging from aunty mold
paint and take home STD tests it's a
phosphorescent alcohol cool damn
straight it is now insisted that my next
tutorial take place in nature
we set out for the newness State Forest
located in the famed Blue Mountains
about five hours west of Sydney it's
there that we hope to find the tiny
creature at the heart of Meow's make
everything feel like a rave dreams
sorry we're about to go to the glowworm
tunnel it used to be a railway tunnel
they used in mining and now it's been a
decommissioned and the glowworms have
come back and Riaan habited the the
tunnel I've waited this long and now I
have to ask you how did you I want to
change my name since I was like 15 my
friends and I just sat down and we just
wrote down a huge list of names and then
we pick the one that sounded the best
what's your full name now yeah Ludo
disco camera meow meow
with the formalities out of the way the
time had come to meet one of Australia's
lesser known biological attractions
glowworms a nocturnal they are generally
less sensitive to red wavelengths of
life and they are white or blue line I
guess to see ambassador we're gonna turn
this off now it talks a lot about a lot
of things sometimes he's hyping a mango
that's been altered to do your laundry
and other times he's promoting
hallucinogen aided orgies to each his
own
but without question meows biohacking
enthusiasm has worked with labs modeled
on this spot popping up all around the
country
prepare yourself Australia for the
phosphorescent revolution has begun